with us now from Capitol Hill as
California congressman Adam Schiff he is
a top Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee which is also investigating
Russian interference in the last
election congressman thank you so much
for joining us this morning thank you so
what are the next steps for your
committee and what questions do you have
for Donald Trump jr. today well I think
the next steps in terms of this issue is
we're going to want to have all the
participants in that meeting anyone who
helped in organizing it and putting it
together come and testify before the
committee we're obviously gonna want to
see any documents any emails
it looks like listening to the
president's son last night on Fox and
hearing his lawyer today that the
defense is going to be yes we had an
intent to collude with Russia we wanted
to get the dirt they Russian government
had in an effort to help elect Donald
Trump but we were deeply disappointed in
not getting it at that meeting that's
not much of a defense and I think you
know we need to look into whether there
was any subsequent efforts whether
indeed we can rely on the
representations about what happened at
this meeting because one thing we have
seen over just the last several days we
can't rely on anything that Donald Trump
jr. has to say about this because his
story has kept changing as he has to
compare to confront the facts coming out
let me ask you there's a new report from
McClatchy that says the House and Senate
intelligence committees of which you are
on are looking into whether the Trump
campaigns digital team guided by Jared
Kushner helped guide Russia's fake news
attacks on Hillary Clinton can you
confirm that what are you looking into
well one of the issues that I think we
need to explore is whether there was any
help in terms of the fake news the
efforts to push negative news by the
Russians whether there was any
coordination in that effort to target
that to identify where it would be
useful to push stories up in people's
social media feeds I'm not saying that
that's what took place but the Russians
use a whole variety of methods to try to
influence not only our elections but
elections in Europe and if there was a
data analytical component to this in
which there was some level of
coordination
we need to look into and to give you
sort of an analogous piece of evidence
here in those emails it's very
significant that Don Jr says hey it'd be
most helpful to get this in the late
summer he's already talking about timing
so if there was any kind of coordination
on the timing of the pushing of either
negative stories or false stories by
Russian social media trolls that's
something we need to know and can ask
because you're a former prosecutor in
this federal campaign finance law
there's stuff about soliciting a foreign
contribution or in-kind contribution
does that raise to that level for you
well you know again I think this is
evidence that goes to the issue of
collusion the question is is it
sufficient evidence and I think we need
to do a lot to corroborate some of the
the evidence that we've received before
we can draw any conclusions but here you
know I think you have quite plainly just
in the four corners of these emails that
have now been released and the
authenticity is not in question
you have three central campaign people
indeed three of the most important
people in the Trump campaign who go to
this meeting with the full expectation
of getting help from the Russian
government and indeed have sent a signal
to the Russian government they would
welcome it they would indeed love it
they've also made a comment about the
timing that would be most useful and
they've talked about frankly admitted
how disappointed they were that in this
particular meeting they didn't get the
dirt the help they wanted from the
Russians so are there issues of whether
there was a potential conspiracy to
violate US election laws that is
certainly a very real issue that needs
to be investigated all right congressman
Adam Schiff thank you very much for your
time this morning
thank you